russian cara el último día de votación
en estas elecciones parlamentarias la
mayor participación se está registrando
a estas horas en las repúblicas de
chechenia y tuba en chechenia a mediodía
había votado más del 70% de la gente se
espera que gane el partido gubernamental
rusia unida es el favorito a pesar de la
caída en sus índices de popularidad por
la crisis observadores independientes
han denunciado en las últimas horas
numerosas violaciones de los
procedimientos de votación las papeletas
al parecer se guardan en contenedores
sin sellar o en salas sin
videovigilancia la campaña ha estado
cargada de polémica desde el principio
muchos candidatos de la oposición no han
sido autorizados a concurrir en estos
comicios y además google y apple
eliminaron de sus tiendas online la
aplicación del disidente aleccionaban y
para intentar redirigir el voto hacia
otros partidos de la oposición putin
necesita mantener su supermayoría
parlamentaria la misma que el año pasado
le ayudó a cambiar la ley y poder
postularse de nuevo a la presidencia en
las próximas elecciones de 2024